i was talking to you about um various things that
i've been doing and i was started having one of
those conversations it was like well obviously
i'm using this and obviously that's happening
and obviously and you said to me well that's not
obvious and i and i realized that there's this
sort of there's that there's a hole in the
computer file catalog other than dave brailsford
very bravely trying to say that html5 is a turing
complete language we haven't really discussed
a lot of the the set of html5 javascript and css
as a whole range of technologies that are now kind
of influencing everything and much as this is old
news for a lot of people i thought this would be
a good springboard to launch some other more
specific videos from reluctant to bring up uh
professor brailsford's uh conversation with me all
those years ago but yeah putting that to one side
things have moved on since that conversation
aren't they well they have and the thing is is
they they things were already in motion back
then but it's taken as ever you know someoneOUBLISh
invents something but then it takes a while
before it becomes just pervasive and sort of
standard practice and i wanted to write a plugin
for premiere because i'm doing a load of video
editing at the moment and when i downloaded the
latest sort of sdk and i was sitting there goingP
through doing some bits and pieces i realized that
there's this thing that's been in premiere for
quite a while which i hadn't noticed where you
can write panels and effectively it's chromium
embedded and it's html5 css and and and
javascript to be able to control these things and
this technology is just so pervasive now and
it kind of hasn't been covered at all where do
we start with this then what's the first one you
want to want to mention well we should start by by
saying you know there's a lot of things that are
similar in ways and um there's certain terminology
during this so for example when i say javascript
a lot of stuff is also done in typescript which is
a more strongly typed version of javascript but
during this conversation when i say javascript
it could also mean typescript and and so we
can't really get into the details of that but
i think the power of this technology
is that anyone can access it for free
i mean anybody out there who has any kind
of computer at all can open up notepad
type in some code and do something run it in a
browser or or download node and run it as a as a
as a terminal application and that's what makes it
powerful and it kind of reminds me of when i was
six years old and starting on an acorn electron
i wrote my first program you could type something
press enter and something happened and we kind
of got far away from that with a lot of coding
particularly like windows based and consumer pcs
and now with things like visual studio code being
just a free download and obviously a browser a
lot more compatible now than they used to be it's
really easy for people to just have an entry point
to doing something cool and i really think html5
css and javascript are a really good entry point
for people who've never done anything before in
the same way that basic was on an acorn electron
or a bbc micro or whatever back in the day
a lot of people don't realize there's loads
of places where the html5 css and javascript
family are being used and one place that is
being used is in visual studio code if you
go out on the net and watch these programming
videos so many people using visual studio code
i think it's the number one ide but that itself
is based on a thing that used to be called atom
and is now called electron which i kind of like
because of the acorn electron link there but
that is effectively a chromium browser running
with you know html5 and css and javascript and
you're kind of got this this desktop app that's
actually kind of like a website in a lot of
ways and it's web technology under the hood so the
story really starts with the google v8 engine okay
which kind of changed everything it's a javascript
engine so back in the day when when sort of
javascript started it was the mozilla lot that
came up it was a very simple scripting language
so that it took the commands processed them in
real time but obviously that's very very slow
when um google were doing chrome and chromium
obviously the open source equivalent they wrote
a thing called the v8 engine which did just
in time compiling of javascript so it would
take the javascript compile it so it ran
a huge amount faster and of course the the
javascript then was way faster than ever been
before and actually became something that could
could to run proper applications from within a
within a browser hence we've now got chrome os
and all these progressive web apps and there's
a guy called ryan dole back in 2009 so a year
later after google would release the v8 he took
the v8 engine and said well what if we don't
use it in the context of the web what if we use
javascript as the language and use their compiler
but we allow it to run terminal applications
like the old sort of command prompt on windows
or a terminal on linux or mac or whatever we allow
terminal applications to be written in javascript
or typescript and that that really kind of changed
the landscape for a lot of people because a lot
of people were writing websites where they'd
have the html css javascript and then that
would talk to an api over over the internet and
that api at the other end might be php or net or
or you know java server page or something
like that and it basically allowed you to
write back in code in the same language and same
style as your front end code um and it had some
really good advantages so javascript as a language
is is is non-blocking so a lot of a lot of um
traditional language so if you look at something
like php or net or those those sort of languages
they'll get the first command and then move on
to the second move onto the third and it's kind
of in line and if you get to a bit where say you
have to do a database lookup it would go off and
look up the stuff on the table and it would wait
for that and then come back and do the next line
of code and it would yeah top to bottom down in
in the kind of linear way yeah like a bit like
basic i suppose yeah process it like that whereas
the way javascript is written is it there's this
there's a thing called the event loop where it
so what you do is you put what it needs to do in
the queue so you could send something off and say
go and fetch that data from the database and then
when it's finished do this and then while
it's waiting for the database to come back
it can move on to the next things that it
might do that are not necessarily linked with
requiring that data so the analogy that i've seen
many times in videos on that is the equivalent of
if you had a restaurant and there's many tables
and you wouldn't want a server coming to the table
and saying what can i get you for for your meal
when they say i'd like steak and chips please
and then he goes back to the kitchen and says we
need to take and chips that save it and just waits
there with the javascript event loop and the way
they cue up the commands the server would go to
the kitchen say he wants steak and chips and then
he'd come back and and get the order from the next
table and cue them up and then when the steak and
chips is ready it would be put on the side and he
can deliver it back to the table and that allows
it to get on and be able to have lots and lots
of concurrent connections and to be able to cope
with lots of little sort of micro tasks without
being held up and then if one
database call takes a while well
javascript will get on with other things until
the database calls finished and it will come back
which makes it perfect for web technology and of
course someone then oh well no no js you know that
we can have that in the desktop and we can write
apps like that and then then someone took node.js
put the chromium browser on top of it and said
well this can be electron so you can write desktop
apps which are cross platform and then you end
up with with vs code and you end up with skype
and you're not with all these applications working
on this technology and people are using them like
desktop and probably don't realize that at the
core it's just javascript and css and html you
know it's just all the same stuff that's powering
gmail and facebook it reminds me a little bit of
technology that obviously and actually i'll
say happily died out flash right it's it's
it's a respect it's interesting because yeah
flash flash was obviously it was was a closed
system whereas this is open you know node is
open source chromium is open source electron is
open source visual studio code that microsoft
write is open source all of these things are
it's the simplicity of it you can get notepad
you can get any notepad thing or whatever the
equivalent is in mac or linux you get that
any text editor and just write something and
run it and it doesn't require a huge amount of
overhead whereas to write something in flash or
do something in flash you had to have the adobe
software to be able to create the flash it was
proprietary right that was the problem there right
yeah it's proprietary it's it's it's so html5
and and that killed flash thanks to pretty much
steve jobs not including it on the iphone and kind
of said no we don't want to go that route this is
a and he was completely right although people were
angry with him at the time he was completely right
to kind of ditch the flash technology so yeah
all of that has come in and replaced
what flash used to do that would fill in
but in a much more set of open standards
and and of course because of that the whole
community has flourished and they've taken
things that were never intended for use outside
the web and put them on the desktop and it's just
stunning to see what you can what you can do now
node which is really was was the key after the
v8 engine of being able to compile javascript
node was the the thing that that broke out of just
being web technology but then from there you had
the node package manager which i'm sure a lot of
viewers would have used npm which is very similar
to to the way um you'd use that get or whatever on
on on ubuntu or you'd use any kind of repository
which allowed you to just install whatever node
module you want so if you want something that can
root so you get a web address say slash user slash
whatever and you want it to run this piece of code
when you get that url you can install express
you know it's very simple one line you install
that module and it allows you and and again it
opened up um it opened up a lot of opportunities
for people who only had been programming in
web technologies to suddenly be able to enter
areas that they would have had to have learned c
or c plus plus or you know c sharp or something
like that to do the more you look round now when
you turn your tv on and you see something come up
the more chances are that you're actually
interacting with this web technology which
really is has been a revolution since 2008 because
of google creating the v8 engine and then node and
these other sort of platforms that take use of
that v8 engine i love the fact that you know
i started an acorn electron the predecessor to
that was the acorn atom and now it's kind of like
atom and now electron it feels feels like there's
someone having a nod back to those beautiful sort
of early 80s days of british computing which which
just you know just adds a bonus to me all we need
now is someone running the acorn and the electron
stuff on a raspberry pi and the circle is complete
well i mean that's the thing you can run i mean
many people out there i mean i've i've written um
i've written a couple of apis that i use to
control some things at home that are in node
that do run on a raspberry pi over wi-fi and
i can i can control various bits and pieces i
had something which was moving the knobs on my
amps for me so i could sit down stairs and turn
up my amp and a little motor would turn the knob
on my amp and that was done via node things that
i never thought were possible to do for example
putting a mixing desk in a browser and being able
to have all the channels of a song and be able to
turn up and down the bass drum and the snare drum
and there's the audio apis that sit underneath
the browser to actually do the hardcore stuff but
you're interacting with that with javascript and
doing stuff that 20 years ago would have been just
out of the league of someone like me to
be able to write you need a whole team
of programmers to do and now you can write
it in a web browser it's it's fascinating
i've bought the rights to use that
picture in any derivative works from it
so if i then reverse engineer the audio from that
picture can i use the audio because it came from
the picture which is in this column so sometimes
we mix diagonals so it'll be a b c d or a b c d
MANUAL PUBLISH